[Music]
three two one action hey guys welcome
back to off-the-record who ever talked
about what you like three months to get
here it was scared for three months well
I wasn't scared was like we just said
you were scared I'm correcting myself
okay well I mean you guys are in a tiny
room like six different people Joe was
trapped in Europe for like three Monty
for Mom
it was super safe here it could the
group that were here like everyone was
quarantined for two weeks and then we
did JK news well you know it was more so
you know I was I was I was down but then
she'll was more a little white collar oh
good for you
what usually happen tom she was just
very um like not paranoid but she wanted
to make sure you know yeah don't do
anything don't go anywhere don't bring
anything
yeah like literally we um I haven't been
seeing anybody's like the pastor man
except for David because we do like a
sane foods in my kitchen situation now
so he didn't want to come here either
hmm you know Apple sees everyone though
he be on hikes and she with them it's
almost like you had JK news already it's
like kissing like um you kissed him and
then he kissed her and then she kissed
me oh she kissed you whoa what happened
dude Timmy your doodles by the way on
Instagram will you go on top of cheese
have you seen it okay quarantine
contents pretty legit dude I know it's
cuz we're just we just literally just
chilling in the house was it inspired by
James Cage white cuz it's kind of like
the same style like he's all hurt yeah
no it was just like um I just got bored
one day I was like oh it's gonna be so
funny so as you're bored in the house
and I'm in the house boy okay yeah yeah
you know we're just you scared geo oh
yeah and he was good
and I'm scared you guys see how I got
verified audience around uh
I got bear fun how did you get verifier
Congrats man you know I was on like a
blood like a bad boy page like they're
not they I was I was just like violated
oh you were like on the blacklisted yeah
because I had a post and I was
responding to a fan that commented Hey
Joe how do you get bigger arms and I say
beating your girlfriend
Oh God and then yeah yeah I made a hole
publicize that comment yeah and then it
got taken down and all that and then so
every time I submitted like well first
my Instagram is all over the place and
on top of that they think that it's like
just garbage and there's nothing written
about are they so judgmental Oh getting
verified on Instagram is a stupid
process and so like you could be a viral
comedian that has a million followers if
you did but and have no verification but
if you could be a [ __ ] journalists
intern at Wall Street Journal for with a
thousand followers and you'll get better
I've seen those yeah you're in the mail
room with like 2,000 followers now yeah
marks yeah cuz of what they see is like
they take a lot of different things into
criteria right so like I had have media
written about me and then I remember I
had someone in a Facebook as a contact
and I had to pull a favor and I was like
can you help me because I got blocked
yeah and then and then she got me in and
I was like oh my god only yes I got
verified cuz I was at Facebook and
they're like oh do you want me verified
I was like yeah [ __ ] yeah and they
didn't you were just like you know we
were already there cuz my agency set up
a meeting with them and then we were
just sure the shows about to wreck is it
isn't it like now way more like
saturated exchanges I have no idea I
think that's how I got verify - I was
always at a setup meeting for like
Facebook and Instagram and you know
influencers and stuff to come through
and then they set me up and stuff I've
been shot I can chia verified for like
years
you know I'm sin and I've been writing
the whole because they asked for
articles about you written media why do
you think she's verifiable cuz she's a
very good blogger okay and her aesthetic
on her page is very pleasing to them
it's way more professional than mine
I don't know if that's blue checkmark or
sheet material Oh and trust me daddy
she has articles written about her -
really daddy oh I just when I say trust
me
did daddy just follows up there was a
trust me daddy it's like a thing daddy
though it's another one my nicknames
Iceman daddy nice man daddy you know the
real Iceman is who who's watching the
Tito Ortiz Chuck Liddell documentary and
chuckle does the Iceman he and then keep
talking about him right and isn't the
whole time thinking about you it's like
the two furthest apart people to the
home is the real Iceman and this one
keeps going
call me Iceman gone the Iceman I'm like
Chuck Liddell didn't even call himself
Iceman other people that's what happened
to me the real Iceman and then this
other guy does you'll see or whatever
you meant to say bro some people told me
that Val Kilmer was Iceman in Top Gun
and I'm like whatever nobody remembers
that well I that was his nickname was
goose no I think it was silly goose
[Laughter]
where did that come from
yeah what's silly good stuff cuz these
are silly [ __ ] good yeah my screaming
I always say this silly goose
well for real now you buy what was your
aim name it was Barto fart oh that was
my nothing more recent one and once
after I grew up a little bit though but
when I was younger
really yeah and one of the O's I think
is a zero forgot which one of us grew up
with a bark oh [ __ ] I was a more mature
high school student I was big sagging
pants for a long time on AIM and then
they were big and they were saying and
you paid it as shoes
what is that cool okay so back when like
Air Force Ones were like super pop in
there was I read an article about how
these rappers were hiring artists to
customize their Air Forces to match
their jerseys and stuff right
this is back in high school so I went to
like my goals by some acrylic paint and
then I would like get a fresh pair Air
Forces and paint them to match like like
my Warriors Jersey or whatever and then
I would just buy warrior [ __ ] you know
I'm saying so I could have like just
matching outfits it was pretty [ __ ]
fly guy though
did anyone Commission you too yeah yeah
I'll paint shoes for kids in school too
yeah as well as sell candy and bootleg
CDs you're a businessman I was always
say like kids that sell [ __ ] from
elementary they usually turn into like
some kind of entrepreneur I think so cuz
they're always selling [ __ ] yeah I mean
I just I didn't want I wanted to buy the
name-brand [ __ ] but I didn't to ask my
parents for it cuz I felt like it's way
too expensive you know to be buying me
[ __ ] Sean John jeans suits and [ __ ]
[ __ ] like three-piece suit talk about
the Jean Jean tuxedo oh I could picture
you totally wearing that for prom and
having a matching dress with your day no
I can't I wish you me maybe now but back
in the day baldon gangster maybe I would
have had a bandana-print suit oh well
color black keep it black can't be a
blood or [ __ ] that's not my style the
bed's pretty cool it's cool it is but I
don't want to get shot remember my dad
came over with bagdana prints no mean
trunks
yeah yeah his shorts he came over one
time and he had like his stretched out
white like undershirt v-neck and then
Joe like ridin sees my dad I'm Joe saw
my dad first closed and her dad streak
rippin because it was so out of place
it's like the woods that the straight
gangsters get at the swap meet and I was
like where the [ __ ] did your dad get
that pair it's mommy
right probably but usually he's wearing
something that Dhoni it was like it
really stood out because it was bright
blue and he'll have like some like
v-neck white tee or something like 20
years old yeah and it just doesn't match
we should have got of a matching I love
that like old Asian people specifically
will wear whatever as long as they like
the color you know I'm saying I didn't
really know what it says sometimes and I
remember just walking through like Asian
markets and seeing grannies with like
NWA t-shirt like my mom used to love
this green t-shirt it was a 7-up shirt
but it was when the make seven up yours
slogan was was on commercials and [ __ ]
so she'd be walking around with a shirt
that said up yours really being on the
bag I don't even know what it meant
now I remember that [ __ ] with Orlando
Jones yeah oh yeah you make seven up
yours
yeah yeah remember when the red circle
is a person - or not a person but it
like it was like yeah yeah yeah it's
like cute like Mickey Mouse hands way
super loops - around yes bright has kind
of like taking over though come to think
about it cuz I've got a key surge more
than this squirms machine at them love
squirt mmm not for you
nah he's a surge kind of guy in all
realms very socially mountain do see
Aramis I like I am actually a third guy
what serious Oh yato
do you remember Serge I never it's like
super caffeine it's what the cool kids
drank apparently I was craving that [ __ ]
it was green like weird like Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtle green and it was so
sweet yeah but so fired but that the
advertising was like people doing
[ __ ] cake
like [ __ ] people like like on
mountains doing [ __ ] skiing and [ __ ]
like surge that would pop up yeah would
you guys get soda postmates postmates it
no but you know what I would get postman
and I do get it post made it is boba oh
yeah I really like boba and my favorite
drink is have you guys ever tried ice
Mill Creek oh yeah that's like Mill
slushies yeah and then like ice and they
like blend it so it's like this frothy
thing and they put this brown sugar
syrup so it tastes really good and I've
been craving that so I get that post
native all the time and if you're like
me you probably start thinking about
what to eat for dinner while you're
eating lunch while I'm eating lunch well
yeah I mean I love food that's why I
love using post mates they deliver fruit
from every restaurant I can think of
right to my door but post mates doesn't
just deliver burgers in sushi they
actually make life easier with grocery
delivery and whatever I can think of
delivery to convenience stores clothing
stores you name it way to get a shirt
that's crazy
so no more trips to the store no more
late-night fast food runs I don't even
have to worry about where to grab lunch
anymore
just download post meets on iOS or
Android find your favorites and get
anything you want delivered within an
hour okay so for a limited time
postmates is giving our listeners $100
of free delivery credit for your first 7
days to start your free deliveries
download the app and use code off the
record that's the code off the record
for 100 more [ __ ] dollars of free
delivery with no minimum purchase for
your first 7 days when you download the
post meets app thank you very much off
the record 10 did you wash your hat with
like a pink shirt no this is how it
looks
why is it a pink socks that it doesn't
make any sense because cuz it's white
socks are cut so what's pink socks on
because fashion my science teacher used
to get so mad when I didn't have Dodger
blue cuz you know how like they had
different colors of the LA Dodgers hat
and they're like why is it brown it
supposed to be Dodger blue yeah and plus
I don't watch baseball so I was gonna
ask him like hey
you know message your kicks though I saw
that it does that wasn't even on purpose
let me see a kick socks are meant to be
worn on your leg
Oh see it's a subtle it's a subtle man
oh I see only a fashionista would be
able to see I see
do you guys watch sports at all um I'm
not like consistent game watcher I'll
always watch um like you're too busy to
beacon
I mean I'll watch like the last ten
minutes of a Laker and Clipper game I'll
always watch you know of course Super
Bowl Finals [ __ ] like that but not
really not consistently I like
highlights same do you guys look forward
to any sports all all highlights sport
highlights fail highlights compilation
porn that's it yeah
news bloopers George Bush's compilation
of failed speeches weatherman fuck-ups
even close over here in the East it's
over here Spanish weather girl turning
and seeing a nice butt compilation those
are the compilations are awesome like
just period anything that you want yeah
land TV I know what
sabado gigante oh yeah yeah no I'm
speaking as fast if you do you guys
watch money heist no that's next on my
cute it's that I heard it really is so
fire it's a it's a Netflix original but
it's um it's a Spain production and it's
all in Spanish so we can watch the dub I
don't need to oh that's tight and here's
the thing about it is okay so the shows
dope literally from the beginning it's
all about like a huge heist in a vein
yeah yeah so but the only thing annoying
about the dub is that you know like the
Spanish language is like really pretty
so I feel like the translation they
translated literally so the dialogue
comes off a little corny
the lips not even the lips just like I
feel like something said in Spanish like
oh you look like the petals on a flower
it sounds so beautiful and then you say
to English like I'm [ __ ] cheesy bro
no no no literally like oh you look like
this Oh flowers on the maybe it's the
voice actors job like they just deliver
a dry
you look like flower petals and stuff
they literally translate it you're not
yeah no that's not that I'm not about it
it's just it doesn't always translate
well oh you would go please oh no I'm
just saying that they always really try
hard to match the lips cuz I was
watching this
kung fu document anything on Netflix and
did you guys know that the kung fu
movies when they dub it into English
it's actually a bunch of white guys
doing it so I thought it'd be like Asian
guys understanding what's going on and
translating but it's just a bunch of
white guys just saying things that they
think is happening like you mean those
kung fu
dubs in the 80s yeah so what the guy so
there's this guy they're interviewing
him he's one of the most famous I guess
dubbers and he was saying well I always
just say I will end you because it
matches all those Chinese lips will do
really yeah he says I say it like I've
said it like four times in every single
so they just rewrite the script see
their own and what they assume they
don't even take the script and then
translate it they just watch what's
happening in the scene and they go what
and you is that the same on where the
the actors from America would come in
and they didn't even know what they were
doing they didn't get any lines or
anything and it was like here you're
gonna go this to this and they're like
what oh yeah so they're also explaining
so they were bringing it over a American
like karate like tournaments narce kind
of like Chuck Norris and trying to make
them into actually like movie stars and
they're saying that the filmmaking
process is way different in Hong Kong
we're here you get a script you gotta
know what the hell is happening when
they're asking can I get this script off
friends like we leave the script just
improv because they go we know what
we're gonna do you just shut up and
listen so there's this one part where
you're just gonna come into this room
and look up and then I think they she
just was like alright so she just comes
in and then looks up and somehow I've
made sense but then it was she finds out
later it was supposed to be something
crazy like someone gets hanged or
something but she didn't even know that
how to motivate her character right they
just told her look up yeah that's the
old school [ __ ] though right yes cuz I
remember watching Crouching Tiger Hidden
Dragon oh that's way different yeah yeah
and there was like this like speech that
the guy made and it sounded so corny and
then but then when I was reading from
people that understood the language they
were like oh this sounds so much better
in whatever Chinese and in that that era
like the Hong Kong golden cinema era or
whatever like their [ __ ] was crazy
because all of that stuff the stunts
they were doing like just watching a
Jackie Chan documentary they did it with
none of the [ __ ] protective gear that
stunt people have today yeah there's
that one police one that he did where
he's at the mall and he's like slow nags
force yeah it's nuts man yeah he just
fought and then he's at the padding that
they had were cardboard boxes he did one
where he's falling down like a
three-story building or a four-story and
he's going through these like I saw that
he's like hitting different things
falling like strategically burly and he
lands on cardboard boxes and rumble in
the Bronx he jumps from one balcony to
another balcony on the other side in
real New York like I actually did it
yeah they go I'm not doing that again
man yeah I think he's like the og
parkour actor for sure like he does some
crazy [ __ ] he's my favorite I know
everyone loves to come all over Bruce
Lee
we love Bruce Lee love Bruce Lee he
started it all that great yes but Jackie
Chan for me was like when I was growing
up on my holy [ __ ] Jackie Chan when you
were girl how did you watch these movies
rumble in the Bronx my grandpa my
grandpa had what we called Miller Buster
where he would pirate all movies that
came out so he would he had a VCR that
he would hook up to whatever is playing
on TV and he would record it and then he
would put it up on top of his TV so he
had [ __ ] 50,000 movies so I was
raised with every [ __ ] movie man yeah
yeah yeah because it was a huge like
kung fu lover so like he had the whole
collection of Bruce Lee with it you know
I could turn it into a dragon there was
a tape
yeah yeah yeah and if you collect all of
them it becomes a dragon it's pretty
dull ma is just my grandpa rode through
the dragon in market weight labels I
watched all the movies because my dad
was a lazy dad so my parents are
divorced someone owes my dad's turn to
have me on the weekend he would just
come pick me up from my mom's house go
straight to the video store and tell me
to rent like eight different VHS is Dan
and he'd go i watch this and then you I
think he went out and gambled videos
that you do you think he's gambling he's
got a stopwatch he's like okay he has
two movies left all right yeah that
sounds like your danceable I don't know
you had this one apartment where like
you know the mattress you actually get
to put it away Murphy bed yeah I thought
that was a dopey shouldn't know in the
world that's called the Murphy play you
know that because of my wife Sam oh yeah
she loves furniture and will she
actually she has a degree in interior
design oh I didn't know that they were
called Murphy beds and she told me about
that [ __ ] and I was like okay cool and
then I was watching an episode of Family
Guy where he was like blah blah blah
yeah last time I had a Murphy bed and
they fold it up the bed and the bed was
like yeah dude [ __ ] it Eddie Murphy joke
if it wasn't for like this random
conversation I had with here yeah
foldaway bed no I wouldn't you've seen
that bed laughs like Eddie Murphy me
like crazy ass like beds don't do that
[Music]
[Music]